there's nothing like that feeling of
hearing the lineup of free playstation
plus games complaining all you want
about whether these games are actually
free or not I really don't care all i
care about is the crazy entertainment i
have in store for me the biggest prize
this month mercenary kings it's a
side-scrolling shooter with crafting
elements talk about a marriage made in
heaven now you can design your ideal
loadout as you mow down nameless troops
you have to admit that it's pretty
amazing getting a brand new ps4 game for
no extra charge next up is Batman Arkham
City and here I was scared we'd get that
middling origins game thank God we
avoided that bollocks now anyone who
hasn't flown through an open-air prison
Gotham can experience the best darn
Batman game ever constructed not too
shabby now we come to a personal
favorite of mine stealth Inc a clone of
the dark is a mind-bending playstation 3
puzzler that made me feel like a genius
sound intrigues I'll check it out it's
not like it's going to cost you anything
to download it and then there's Castle
volusion starring mickey mouse on the
playstation 3 this is how to remake a
classic for modern era it's absolutely
gorgeous and still fun to play who knew
throwing apples as a mouse could be so
fun we end things with a couple Vita
games velocity ultra may look simple but
it's so clever and so fun you won't care
about the visuals in pixel junk monsters
ultimate HD is one of those charming and
enthralling tower defense games around
so that's it for April have fun playing
all these exciting games and be glad
that they won't cost you any money free
you